wir fliegen auf einem fischkutter gerade
trade optimedia waren freudig wirklich
was gleich vier mal herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu einem neuen bedingungen
wäre schon ein zettel eingeblendet wie
spielen heute kein normales spiel
ja wahrscheinlich ist er kein normales
spiel wir befinden uns heute in gta und
vielleicht kennt ihr schon gta ich denke
jeder kenne eigentlich gt hd theater ins
spiel indem man einfach wie in der
echten welt rumlaufen kann wir befinden
uns in los angeles das da vorne downtown
können beispielsweise mülltonnen um
treten monaten ab was man zum beispiel
auch machen kann es verstecken spielen
ich bin gerade einen bus er hat mich
ganz komisch angeguckt egal ob die
presse
wir wollen aber heute nicht ganz normal
gta spielen sondern ich habe mir eine
mod installierung zwar kann ich f4
drücken und wir sehen schon native
trainer eingeblendet jetzt kann ich
einfach durch wird schlägt
beispielsweise auch vier kicker auch
kart- borna und ihr seht wahrscheinlich
esel und titel eingeblendet wenn ich
jetzt die fünf drücke dir schon bin
ich kann jetzt beispielsweise auf die
schippe drauf klettern und stehen und
auf dem wittener das ist genau das was
man mit witz bin nämlich zum 8 wir
wollen uns aber nicht herausstellen
sondern wir drücken einfach mal 1100
wien schon franklin steigt auf den
fidschis spinner trennten hatten helm
aufdecker erschweren kann ich mich
normalerweise eher weniger ich weiß
nicht warum ich jetzt gerade verrückt
bin aber irgendwie war der titel sowohl
im weg von anderen gegenständen da bleib
ich glaube ich werde mir einfach
irgendeine karikierten was könnte man
den hinnehmen aus wieder hört ja nicht
ganz klug ich dachte der kotten
schnelles auto aber nein da kommen bot
ich weiß nicht was hier gelten sind
irgendwie in dem spiel ich will einfach
hingestellt auto mit dem ich dann im ort
fahren kann wo ich die karten wir den
titel holen kann
2000 jahre später habe ich mir doch mal
endlich eine karre gefahren
plötzlich ganz die karte karre aber naja
ich meine kann fahren die venen schon da
hinten die golden gate bridge eingeben
die golden gate bridge dies eigentlich
gar nicht in los angeles wir müssen
jetzt nur zu irgendeinem ort fahren wo
wir ein bisschen mehr platz haben damit
wir doch den viertel knapp vorne können
hier wird sogar ein geschwungenes
gutwillig berger fest ich drücke wieder
r4 wir klicken wieder auf ein milliliter
und wir sehen schon jahr der vierten
liga läuft nicht weg vor mir
wir sind in der luft mit dem fit bin an
meine damen und herren entwickelt gerade
ein bisschen ruckeln halt einfach ein
bisschen wie fliegen erst mal wird ihn
auf flughöhe hier den schon der fall
gerade nicht die golden gate bridge hier
mit relativ gute höhe erreicht und
können jetzt beispielsweise einfach mal
wenn wir die linke maut zu drücken wird
hier nach vorne fliegen
für mich ist gerade ultra cool weil ich
ja selber noch vor einem monat in los
angeles war unter anderem am strand war
oder davor die situation war hotel
gerade megageil zu wählen
ich frag mich was werten die trainer
hier machen können also wir können
einfach mal vom parkett machen die
wenigsten helikopterlandeplatz jetzt
einfach mal darauf gelandet ich bin
jetzt nicht der allergrößte gta profi
und dieter pötsch ist auch nicht das
beste was man hier irgendwie steuern
kann aber ich würde
sie sind schon relativ nah dran und
versuchen nach auf dem landeplatz auf
parker leute der putz brand gerade
irgendwie und hat irgendwelche schramm
schon am rand vermutlich anzahl das ding
wieder hoch zu kriegen aber teilweise
und jetzt geht
ich wusste dass es nicht klappen wird
also fährt sich eigentlich ganz gut der
beute tuner hat eine schnelle karte
alter haben wir so ein bisschen rum hier
kann ich vielleicht mein führerschein
wiederholen ich werde hier vorne jetzt
einfach mal noch im fitnesssport
quickborner any layer da haben wir dann
für display hatte ich mich auch fragen
ich kann ja auch world klicken dann kann
ich auch mit gravity klicken und jetzt
ist die multi an derzeit theoretisch wtf
freunde irgendwie befinden wir uns
gerade in der schwerelosigkeit aber und
soll das eigentlich nicht weiter
juckenden wir haben hier unseren fit bin
können einfach mal auf dem kiez kicker
hier drauf steigen wir haben das ding
einfach mal an fliegen hoch und venen
schon da unten massenkarambolage gewesen
aber egal wie es auf unseren fußball hat
sich auf jeden fall noch mal eben mit
dem finger testen wollte war was
passiert wenn wir damit in die
militärbasis liegen eigentlich ist
dieser clip gehalten stinknormaler
hernie leider also quasi kein helikopter
aber trotzdem so eine art helikopter und
ich frag mich einfach was in der
militärbasis dann vor sich geht wenn ich
mit diesem hit it's been a einfach mal
den besuch abstatten
entweder freunde videodaten mich ich
weiß gerade nicht ganz genau wo die
militärbasis genau da vorne ist
militärrat
wir fliegen auf einem fit bin ja gerade
trade optimedia baden freut mich
wirklich was gleich passiert
normalerweise sind der media war sowohl
das wenn man sich der nähe oder den muss
man direkt vom sterne bekommen wir sind
schon da unten ist gerade im bett
gelandet wie winnenden verbotenen
luftraum drehen sie sofort ab da werde
ich natürlich nicht nur wir wollen
jetzt wissen wir was passiert wenn man
mit einem finger in die militärbasis in
gta 5 liegt das aber auch hier von video
meine damen und herren wenn es euch
gefallen hat wie ich mich per bahn like
freund schreibt meine kommentare
irgendwelche anderen gta rottweil ich
habe jetzt endlich mal zum laufen
bekommen dass ich in gta 5 installieren
kann und es gibt zum mega krankheit es
gibt auch noch irgendwelche anderen
tipps wo man drehen kann in der hand
gibt auch noch im sinne der boden lava
motto da keine ahnung was auf jeden fall
richtig richtig viel richtig kranke
grafik muss also lasst leichter wenn ich
das noch machen soll schreiben die
kommentare und schreibt in einem
kommentar
denn jetzt noch dran seid und jetzt
würde ich sagen
rollvi auto
ihr könnt jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
strecken jetzt wenn ich jetzt bei
anderen videos nach unten könnt ihr auch
die glücklichen anwesenden richtungen
[Musik]